India and that whole region of the world
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey my
brother jab eco a has apparently hit
800,000 subscribers
trailing this channel good luck catching
up there brother eat our dust sucka he
has a video out called the 800 K dance
he specifically asked me to check it out
and like a good younger brother I say
yes to every 10 requests he has 800,000
subscribers this Kawai family is over
800,000 people strong to retain I want
to touch a little bit different this
time by having a char do something and
that is I asked her to dance to the
theme song of most of my videos and she
said I won't dance
I will move in a way I see fit to the
music it's not dancing it's just sort of
movement and so it's a bit of a goofy
thing but I think that you guys will
thoroughly enjoy it
we've spent a lifetime shooting and
editing this thing and I hope you get a
laugh and I really really hope you guys
enjoy it I found it very amusing and fun
so here it is to celebrate 800,000
subscribers
thank you I know I know that Ali
I know all these locations
[Music]
alright rockin that denim best genus
[Applause]
[Music]
didn't recognize it
magnetic market
that's the best buy parking lot over
there
Pacific Theater all the
behind-the-scenes stuff
this is dancing give me a movement piece
okay yeah it's gonna be like
interpretive
this actually must've been very hard to
edit the countryside the whole thing
oh seven more chars video that it is
shabby go easy yeah
my hope is that he'll come out and start
dancing at the very end I really hope
you guys enjoyed that as much as we did
and you guys are awesome thanks so much
for being part of the coif family thank
you for getting us to eight hundred
thousand subscribers really [ __ ] four to
nine hundred thousand subscribers I love
you all not a really pretty you're gonna
hold an emollient and you being part of
this and hanging out with us you all are
so awesome and I couldn't ask for a
better internet family y'all are the
best thank you thank you I love you I am
javi kawaii peace out Oh emotions I bet
that took him 16 retakes to come across
as authentically grateful with him I
being genuinely sincere yet Aras like
the smile mo I can't smile
this is after-effects that was fun video
congratulations I know that was probably
a [ __ ] two-headed sometimes a chart
edit sometimes he edits but I know that
he's very particular about timing on
certain things making sure to hit every
beat the Chara knows how to move man for
you a Chara yeah busting out those
grooves man you could sell your own like
dance tape you know teaching people how
to do it see that is a Chara though
that's super hurt yeah yeah that's very
much who she is I know I usually see her
in videos where she's very like just
stationed stationary so she can't really
move around a lot but in real life is a
very goofy person it's nice to see this
side of her look I bet she had a blast
doing it if I were to venture a guess
jab you probably choreographed all of it
passing like it's like free flow and
just record yeah still let her improv he
was very specific about everything she
had to do very anal there's no improv on
a jab Ocoee I don't trust anybody now
come on
right lie to him run the shoot him dad
camera let him direct let him do the
acting him do the craft all that I mean
all the money that he spent to buy all
these subscribers mm-hmm looks like it's
really paying off man yeah man the
amount of views he buys I have
occasionally my therapist tell me that I
often go into denial and believe a lot
of false things to try to minimize the
pain that inflicts my ego and levels of
jealousy however I don't have to deal
with that this time because I know facts
and he bought all this that's the kind
of guy I know your brother to be I mean
he's just all about building himself up
whatever cutthroat way possible yeah
that means paying monthly to get more
and more subs to make himself look
better hey I mean he's gonna do it
that's perseverance for real it's not
about earning it's about buying
I mean it's about reinvesting so
congratulations on reinvesting
consistently because once you get that
number up to a million whoo you can get
product placement and that's where
that's where the gold that revenue yeah
well practically pay for what you're
paying to get all those subscribers I
know it's risky and arguably us putting
that out there puts you in danger
I know if there's anyone in this YouTube
sphere who gets paranoid about the
littlest things going wrong with their
channel it's definitely you
let's hope that no one on YouTube comes
across this video and decides to
investigate I mean the way you're
trailing us I can't imagine that people
aren't gonna see this yeah I mean you're
clearly just in our shadow yeah entirely
and this is gonna have some big
repercussions so maybe you start
thinking about changing things every
time you think you're in the spotlight
we're just we just keep eclipsing you
buddy and I'm so sorry that we
consistently do that yeah especially
that time we visited India and everyone
was like oh my god we are we Jack's we
love your American conjurer your your
your Greg's brother right jabya that's
what everyone said to you in India so
really this is 800k video is all because
this is all because it's all because
people subscribed from our
annal on to yours every time we welcome
ya on one of your videos you know every
time we retweet one you know it's just a
hundred more subs to use the thing is if
you look at the the way numbers are
brought in and analyzed you and you see
those like n screens and cards that
appear on your videos people usually
click one so the thousands of views that
you've gotten from being in our videos
people are only clicking your button so
you're welcome yeah that's all from our
n screens and our one hundred percent
retention rate yeah people always make
it to the last 27th for sure everyone
who's watching this video has made it to
this point yeah Debbie do 96% watch time
but seriously I live in denial and I'm
okay with that I hope you're well and
Jerry
I hope he's well I mean he seemed a
little emotional in this video getting
up to that that high bar his eyes are
red
not because he's emotional he's very
tired he's sleepy yes he didn't actually
want to shoot you he's not touched by
the level of success and all the fans
he's garnered over the years of hard
work and dedication he's just very
sleepy all right well well we got
another minute here guys say let's erase
all that and say congratulations you
really earned it you're you're one of
the hardest-working people I know we
were even slightly texting the other day
of this Instagram post he started doing
reactions because of this channel he
found his own niece she found his own
market to go into and and now he's at
where he's at his numbers are so much
better this job like the subscriber
account of the average view count so
much better but what I really appreciate
that I'm happy he's successful because
he's learned so much that has allowed us
to implement certain things in our
channel let us help this channel still
grow still we can make a living off the
channel yeah because a lot of things
that he's shown us a lot of different
tips here and there I think the editing
is also improve our thumbnails
everything's really improved because a
lot of the advice he's gone and whenever
ever like and some crazy YouTube Fiasco
like at that time last year in December
where our channel was taken away from us
for like a month use that weird thing
were it's still up there but we just
can't access it what the hell
and he was really involved in helping us
out whenever we've had like our computer
just broke cool it's going on he is
always there especially the technical
side of things or we have a laptop now
that we bought off of him and it's like
he went to the MAC store got it all line
analyzed and made sure it was a full
working order
he's always so busy but he's always
going the extra mile for example he's
always buying subscribe you don't have
to do that in fact it's strongly
discouraged but that doesn't stop now
because I can't stay sincere you can't
have that I have to be sarcastic yeah
that's how people know that you care
that says they know Oh American yeah I
don't know all right show me one other
country that has sarcasm no whenever I
go on his channel very fortunate that it
seems like most people like me so I'm
happy I think I'm considered a part of
the Co a family well because of all
those people being you know robots and
stuff oh yes what happens when you buy
something real not real yeah so you just
have a bunch of agreeable machines well
I hope all eight hundred thousand of you
robots will eventually develop
intelligence and and subscribe to the
real it subscriber the real rejects
after you not intelligence consciousness
taken artificial intelligence yeah I
wonder aw [ __ ] know if like that
consciousness that's what I was trying
to go get some intelligently that sounds
mean why's that sound mean I thought of
using the proper term yeah a bunch of
morons
alright well subscribe to the Co a
family Jabby Kuwait he has videos where
he covers American videos get Jabby
Achara
exists on the internet too somewhere
dancing in this video good bye people